[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new venom to carnage in
spider-man Easter eggs video some new
venom to trailer scenes seemingly made
it online recently featuring the carnage
symbiote so there's obviously a bunch of
Easter eggs and references will break
down I will be doing a full venom 2
trailer video soon so definitely hit
subscribe if you haven't already to be
one of the first to see that when it
comes out I believe it's supposed to
come out in the next month or so but the
virus shutdown has delayed everything
just a little bit thankfully they
finished filming venom two before the
big shutdown and they've just been
editing the movie and doing special
effects remotely everyone post all your
spider-man worked from home jokes in the
comments so I'll talk about the new
venom two scenes the carnage character
the Easter eggs and then I'll talk about
Tom Hollands spider-man and what their
current plan is for having him cross
over with the venom character because
that plan is a little bit different for
their plans in the Morbius movie just
breaking this all down top five WTF
style starting with number five if you
didn't see it some footage that seems
like it's from the venom 2 trailer made
it online recently some of it seems real
some of it seems fake so I'll try to
make it clearer what I think is real and
what I think is fake this first scene is
of the carnage symbiote obviously it's
hard to tell if the symbiote has already
bought add to cletus kasady it seems
like it's reaching out in the form of a
hand with the really elongated blade
like fingers the carnage has in the
comics even though the symbiotes can
still form any shape that they want when
they're not bonded to anyone this scene
seems a little more legit so if you
wondered why Sony would allow stuff like
this to get out you may remember just a
couple months ago
Sony purposefully allowed some Morbius
scenes to leak out right before it
released the official Morbius trailer as
part of an early viral marketing
campaign to just get people excited
about the idea of spider-man showing up
because one of the scenes that leaked
out was that wall picture of
spider-man's costume with Morbius
walking by it
obviously that worked because everybody
went crazy for a while before they
released the official trailer and then
sure enough the scene showed up in the
trailer so it seems like Sony might be
doing the same thing for venom 2 and
right now we're actually way beyond the
time frame when Sony originally was
dropping trailers for the first venom
movie so they should be dropping
trailers for venom 2
really soon if not right now so it just
seems like they're capitalizing on more
viral marketing for venom two before
they dropped the official trailer this
scene actually seems like the carnage
symbiote has bonded with Cletus Kasady
because you have to go based on the
rules for symbiotes they established in
the first venom movie and in that movie
the symbiotes who had not bought it to
anyone mostly just existed as piles of
goos that oozed around once they bonded
to different people each of the
different ones including venom started
forming more aggressive shapes the
symbiote blades sharpened teeth there is
a lot of context for where and when this
scene is happening in the movie normally
you see bars and you think prison but
based on what the Morbius movie is
setting up for venom - it seems like
they're trying to speed up the whole
process of Cletus Kasady breaking out of
prison and going after Eddie Brock in
the movie version of Cletus Kasady they
establishes just a psychopath who's
obsessed with Eddie Brock it's implied
they have some kind of history together
maybe Eddie's journalism help put Cletus
behind bars either way it kind of
explains why he wants to get Eddie so
badly and during that as presumably when
Cletus learns about the existence of the
Venom symbiote which then later spawns
offspring in the form of the carnage
symbiote so number four there's a scene
of a very large Cathedral they film
scenes out for the movie that shows up
in this footage the whole concept of
venom in a Cathedral should ring all the
Nostalgia bells for anyone who grew up
reading spider-man comics in that
original venom origin story as well even
Tobey Maguire spider-man 3 which kind of
tried to keep its venom origin story as
close as possible to the comic book
origin story they changed the venom
origin story in the first venom movie so
it's no surprise that they changed the
carnage origin story a little bit too so
that it all makes sense but it seems
like they're at least trying to keep it
as familiar as possible so it seems that
they might be giving carnage some of the
aspects of the original fan of origin
story in the original carnage origin
story venom had been separated by Eddie
Brock by spider-man in the previous
fight he got thrown in a New York City
prison his cellmate just happened to be
Cletus Kasady
when the Venom symbiote came to bust
Eddie out of prison by coincidence it
spawned an offspring without realizing
it in that offspring left behind at the
scene eventually bonded to the nearest
host which just happened to be Cletus
Kasady forming full comic book carnage
the whole reason why they created the
car
character in the comics is because they
wanted to turn venom into more of an
antihero and team em up with spider-man
briefly so they needed a threat that was
bigger and crazier than venom obviously
they're also kind of using that for
eventual venom spider-man crossover and
team up because venom in the movies is
supposed to be an antihero number three
this is just a regular scene of Cletus
Kasady after he's gotten the carnage
symbiote walking around in plain clothes
form notice that he's got the short hair
now buzzed off that bad wig thank you
very much
he's wearing a red and yellow Hawaiian
shirt pretty obviously to color code him
red for a carnage red the symbiotes can
make themselves look like anything any
type of clothing that they want or armor
but the way they played that in the
first venom movie is that Eddie would
just wear his normal street clothes
around and the Venom symbiote would just
unfurl itself around his whole body when
they needed to fight so the symbiote
wasn't making itself look like his
jacket or anything like that there were
a couple scenes of them filming Cletus
in this outfit recently where federal
agents were attempting to open fire on
him in the middle of the street based on
the way the stunt double is moving with
his arms splayed out all wide the
carnage symbiote seems like it just
manifests around him like a meat shield
eating all those bullets and even though
most people think of comedy when they
think of Woody Harrelson like he just
did the zombie land sequel with Ruben
Fletcher who's the person who directed
the first venom movie which is probably
the reason why Woody Harrelson was
selected as their version of carnage
he's also really great at playing those
creepy intense characters think really
deep Oliver Stone cuts
Natural Born Killers Woody Harrelson and
talk about even deeper Marvel cuts
Robert Downey jr. mr. Iron Man himself
was also in that movie so a lot of these
other big action scenes that don't
involve the Venom symbiote where he's
just out by himself and the police are
trying to apprehend him yet do think of
it as being a crazy twist on all the
scenes in the venom movie where he got
the symbiote but he didn't know what was
going on yet like he's in his apartment
just freaking out and it just starts to
automatically help him when the goons
come to get him only because it's the
carnage symbiote it's just way more
vicious I am interested to see how they
try to do this as pg-13 versus being a
rated R venom movie carnage is one of
those really hard characters but he's
not like toxin level hardcore I know a
lot of you are hoping that they do the
toxin symbiote at some point they did
tease a long time ago when they were
making the first venom movie that they
were
hoping to get to a bunch of other
iterations of the Venom symbiote in
toxin is just the next step after
carnage the number two there are a
couple other trailer scenes that some of
you asked me about that I think are
actually fake there's a scene of a file
with Cletus Cassidy's name on it it says
case number but just has a stamp listing
2018 the year the first venom movie came
out the reason I think this is fake is
because if it were real it would
probably have an actual case number
instead of a date stamp then there's
this scene of the full-blown carnage
symbiote which also kind of seems like
it's fake just because it looks like a
bad Photoshop job what I'm hoping they
did with the carnage symbiote is that
they actually made it look quite a bit
different from the Venom symbiote
obviously it's gonna have to be based on
some of the design language of the
symbiotes just different enough in
composition and form from the Venom
symbiote so that it doesn't look like
they totally phoned it in and copy
pasted the Venom symbiote and just color
swapped at red carnage is supposed to be
the offspring of the Venom symbiote so
it should feel totally different like a
new creation that looks nothing like the
other symbiotes from the first movie in
number one WTF obviously what about the
Spider Man Easter eggs for Tom Hollands
spider-man in the Marvel movies there
were reports last year when the Sony
Marvel stuff was going down that Sony
was working with Tom Hong to try and
sign him to a special cameo deal to
physically appear in venom two in some
small way Tom Holland has done a bunch
of interviews where he talks about
wanting to crossover with venom for the
past couple of years so it sounds like
he's really down to do that the future
for spider-man was still very bright
with Sony and we had a really really
wonderful idea of how we could sort of
transition into a spider-man without the
MCU and Tom Ross been a named Pascal
were really confident that they were
gonna do justice and make a film of the
caliber that spider-man requires but
that said I'm really glad to be back in
the MCU and to have the team back
together because I kind of feel like
it's where he belongs now I'm really
grateful that Bob Iger and Tom rossmann
allowed me to be a part of the process
of bringing him home but he's also been
working on a bunch of other movies the
past year so when most my expectation is
that he shows up in a very very short
cameo scene at the end of venom two or
maybe a venom two post credits scene
referencing the beginning of spider-man
3 an eventual crossover between venom
and spider-man in future sequels you all
saw Michael Keaton's
show up in the more BIA smoothie he has
a small role during that film so I'm
assuming that if Tom Holland shows up in
venom 2 it'll be even smaller than what
you see of Michael Keaton in the Morbius
movie the other real big spider-man
venom 2 connection is actually through
the J jonah Jameson character who's
supposed to be cameo in the Morbius
movie and venom 2 providing some loose
sense of continuity between spider-man
far from home all these sony movies in
spider-man 3 I'm assuming that's mostly
gonna be him showing up on the Daily
Bugle dotnet website and video screens
yelling about spider-man being on the
loose I'll be doing more Marvel
spider-man and Doctor Strange 2 videos
soon so everyone just leave your
requests and big questions in the
comments below
everyone click here for my brand new
Morbius spider-man Easter Egg video and
click here for my brand new spider-man 3
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight